hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
any book one on Duty's Cicero is going
to explore the virtue of justice in a
very important way now on duties is
Cicero's presentation of stoic ethics in
particular ethics in terms of the four
cardinal virtues and quite often when
people are approaching these four
cardinal virtues as wisdom justice
courage and temperance they think that's
something that's been left out and the
stories actually have some very
important clarifications of that and
this indeed is one of those very
important clarifications because the
sister was going to tell us that justice
doesn't just include what we might call
strict justice it also includes what we
can translate as beneficence or as you
might say a different kind of goodness
that falls under justice beneficence is
not a word that we typically use it's
actually it's just a transliteration of
the Latin benefit Kennedy which means
doing good to other people so we might
call it in another old fashioned word
charity Cicero actually does use the
word Caritas at certain points he more
often uses these other terms which we'll
discuss shortly but the general idea is
that justice as a virtue is something
wider something more encompassing than
merely following the rules or fulfilling
you know what is do you know following
the roles and expectations that you have
it includes the things that we would
term you know going beyond giving
engaging in charity work or volunteer
work all of those can fall under
beneficence so let's start where Cicero
actually begins this he talks about
justice as a virtue that is
good character trait something that we
want to emulate something that we want
to see in ourselves and others and like
each of the virtues justice has its very
basis in human nature and it's something
that we as the kind of animals that we
are that as rational animals are you
might say designed or intended in some
way to have as part of the way in which
we comport ourselves so it depends on
some inclinations that are implanted
within the very core of human nature
very often not realized sometimes only
realized partly all of that is quite
true but all of these inclinations are
there and Cicero says that one of the
major inclinations that we have is what
we could call the social instinct we
want to gather together with in
functioning groups and societies and we
need justice in order to do that well so
at one point he talks about justice as
maintaining human society that's just
you know so Keith Haas and a community
or as the translation here it has common
bonds of life communitas vitae that is a
life that we live together not as
isolated individuals but as individuals
who are in relation to each other in an
ongoing way of common life now this is
actually going to encompass something
quite wide and in the end one of the
things that he does talk about those
dogs were Cosmopolitan's this is this in
theory encompasses the entire human race
but generally we think about things that
are closer to us the family our friends
our local community our our nation or
our state and he tells us in in
consequence of this that justice
actually has two parts or that is virtue
has two parts
then he says is called justice he says
there are two divisions justice which is
the crowning glory of the virtues and on
the basis of which men are called good
men and then he says clothes akin
conn-young to that is like conjoined -
it's actually one of the words that is
used for talking about spouses can join
with justice is beneficence benefi Ken
TIA
he says which may also be titled
kindness for generosity so each of these
is really part of justice real ours
there's justice in a strict sense which
includes a lot of different things I'm
not going to try to tell you all of it
here but here are some examples of what
Cicero places under other than that
so giving others what is due to them
giving others what they deserve
you know distributing offices or
resources or even punishments or or
detriments fairly that's one notice of
justice he very much stresses not
harming other people not allowing others
to come to harm when we can prevent it
as also being part of justice and then a
third really important thing is when we
make commitments or promises or incur
obligations that we actually put a fill
them and that is justice in the strict
sense he also includes many other things
under that same sort of rubric you know
for example talking about how we want to
treat the enemy in wartime the Stoics
did believe in something like a Just War
theory that would fall under strict
justice we need more than that that's
not enough to have the entire virtue
that allows us to live together well in
human society this is a problem that
gets discussed by many moral theorists
and you know you could say something
like this well so long as I don't
transgress anybody else's rights and I
keep my
and other stuff what does it matter if
I'm nice to them what does it matter if
I speak to them what does it matter if I
have you know invite them to my backyard
barbecues what does it matter if I
exchange things with them what does it
matter if I pitch in when they're having
some trouble that that's all besides the
point I don't have to do that sort of
thing
Cicero and the Stoics would say well if
that's your attitude you're not really
just because you're missing this other
half of the virtue of justice there's
justice in the strict sense that's very
good don't skimp on it
but there's also beneficence to be
magnificent well let's look at some of
the things that he says about it he says
we can also call this kindness one of
the words that he uses over and over
again is bending but making a pass which
means being which is the word we get
benign from being good to others giving
them things helping them out generosity
liberally toss this is another key idea
that in some ethics will be separated
off as a separate virtue Cicero is
placing that under justice under
beneficence he uses other terms like you
talk to us about friendship i'ma keep
TIA
he talks about love for those within
your family you know more he talks about
what we might call you know giving
kavita's or affection he also talks
about benevolence which is just a
transliteration of that Evelyn TIA which
is very similar to beneficence
benevolence stresses the attitude the
wheeling part beneficent stresses the
actually doing something part so you
could be benevolent in a certain sense
but never actually
you weren't able to distribute any goods
to other people so this covers a wide
range this might have to do with how you
give people money it might include what
you do with your time what you do with
your attention whether you in fact
treat people well whether you have a
kind word or a smile for somebody who's
down all of that can fall under
beneficence the other thing that's very
important to stress about this is that
Cicero does not think that we have you
might call a sort of unlimited universal
requirement of beneficence he stresses
that in fact we we can't be beneficent
towards everybody except in a very
limited way we might in fact have to
choose between you know different people
who we give our rare resources to or who
we spend our time with and he thinks
that there are some some general or
basic rules or principles that we can
use to understand how we ought to
apportion this so beneficence and
justice actually connect up with each
other in another way because justice
informs beneficence beneficence goes
beyond what strict justice requires but
it's also still going to be governed to
some extent by strict justice
particularly giving others what is due
to them so these two together comprise
the actual virtue of justice for Cicero
and we don't want to leave this part out
if we do leave this part out then we're
not really just in the sense that the
Stoics talked about so he devotes a lot
of attention to discussing the ins and
outs of beneficence another thing to
keep in mind is that you know this is
much more likely to be part of what we
could call our personal life we should
be just in the strict sense in our
person
life but this is where we have the realm
of our relationships that play
themselves out so both of these are
going to be about equally important in
realizing this social inclination or
instinct whatever you want to call it
and perfecting it rationally making it
into a virtue
you